our next application
of multi-objective least squares is
something called regularized data
fitting
it's a very powerful method to improve
fitting models so let's start with the
motivation
so let's consider fitting a data model
uh uh
that of some relationship that we guess
holds like you know y is about equal to
f of x f is some unknown function
and what we'll do is we'll use a linear
in the parameters model and that looks
like this
we will choose um basis functions f1
through fp of x and then what we'll do
then is will fit to the data
the parameters in the model that
multiply these basis functions that's
going to be theta 1
up to theta p here so that's uh that's
going to be the
the idea and we're going to assume here
that f1 of x
is 1. it's the constant that's very
that's very common and that means that
this first term
in the model is just theta one people
refer to that as the offset in the model
okay now recall that one one
interpretation of what theta i
is is it's how sensitive our prediction
f hat of x is to f i of x
so for example if i told you that theta
3 equals zero you would conclude
that in fact f sub 3 of x has no effect
whatsoever
on our prediction on the other hand if
theta 4
were for example extremely large that
would mean that for just small changes
in for very small changes in f4 of x
in the fourth uh basis function
um if very small changes that would lead
to very big changes
in the prediction in other words it
would be very sensitive our prediction
would be very sensitive
now the idea here is that that's a bad
idea
um oh i should mention one thing there
is an exception
if we look at theta if we look at i
equals one
theta one multiplies uh something uh
a a a basis function that's constant and
which is absolutely constant it doesn't
change
so theta one which is the offset in the
model cannot you know we don't interpret
that as
a sensitivity okay so the conclusion of
all this and this is
all very rough it's just basic intuition
is this is
we do not want theta two up to theta p
to be large
um and if someone says why don't you
want them to be large you say well that
makes
the larger they are the more sensitive
my model is to what the values of these
basis functions is okay that's the idea
oh we don't care about theta one theta
one is can be whatever
it wants to be okay so this is all vague
but this is the motivation for
regularization
and so what we're gonna do in
regularization is is just have two
objectives
one is going to be the traditional least
squares fit
on on your data and the second is going
to be that we would like theta 2 to
theta p
to be small okay so
let's suppose we have a a training data
set
um and what we're going to do is we are
going to express
the error on this training data set as a
theta
minus y these are capital n vectors uh
here
so uh these are the n vectors consisting
of
you know y one through y n on the right
hand side that's this one
and um and this on the
this thing is y hat evaluated at x one
up to x
n okay and the matrix a remember is
something like the basis functions
evaluated at the data points
all right so regularized data fitting
goes like this
you start the primary objective is the
usual least squares
objective it's this that that's the sum
of the squares of the prediction errors
so that's we obviously want that small
and in fact in least squares simple
least squares data fitting
you simply make that small that's what
least squares data fitting is
we're going to add we're going to make a
by criterion problem we're going to add
a second a second
objective and the second is this one
says this
is the this is the the
sum square of the prediction errors
this one says at the same time i would
like the coefficients theta two up to
theta p to be small
and we do this and lambda is called the
regularization parameter here
this is called regularizing the data fit
data fitting procedure
okay we'll talk about how you would
choose lambda
in a minute um now for a regression
model
um this turns out that this has a very
simple look
it's simply here y hat is explicitly x
transpose
beta x is the data matrix uh plus nu
times
one uh that's the one the vector of all
ones
here and what we minimize is this that's
that's the vector of y
hats and then here what we do
is theta 1 is v
and we don't that we don't regularize
but we do regularize the other which is
beta
so we simply make this thing up here now
here let's mention a couple of things of
what happens
right when um when lambda is
zero you recover just least squares data
fitting period that's it you just you
minimize the sum of the squares of the
prediction errors
end of story when lambda gets really big
this whole thing it you'll basically
you're basically saying i put a huge
cost
on on having the coefficients theta two
to theta p
being non-zero and so basically as
lambda goes to infinity
theta goes to uh that theta two to p
goes to
goes to zero and theta one uh actually
is going to go to the mean of the data
because what it means is that when
lambda is really big
this reverts to the constant model
and remember that the best constant
model of uh some data is the mean
um and by the way the the mean square
prediction error is the
uh the is the square of the rms value
of y okay so that's that's what that
does
oh another word for regularization is
shrinkage
that's used in statistics and the reason
is pretty clear what it does is
this serves to shrink the coefficients
uh to make them smaller than they would
be
if you didn't have that term okay um now
how do you choose lambda
well here there's a very good way to do
it what you typically do
is you would actually build your model
this way and you'd work this you know
you do this for 20 30 different values
of lambda
traditionally and just as a practical
matter those are spread over a very
large range
and they're also typically
logarithmically spaced
so you would work out you'd get 20
different models 30 something like that
with different values of lambda you get
a completely different
model then what you do is you go and
take that model and you evaluate every
single one of those
on the test data set and then you look
for
you look for the point which has the
best test error
actually honestly what people do a lot
of times is they choose lambda a little
bit bigger than that
because all other things being equal the
larger lambda is
kind of the smaller the theta 2 to p is
and therefore the
less sensitive your model is right and
that's just always a good thing
to have an insensitive model okay
so we're going to look at an example
it's a very simple example
it goes like this we have uh
a um we have a truth in this case it's
all made up so we have a true function
f y equals f of x um actually plus a
little bit of noise
um so the true function is this
uh something that has this form with a
sinusoid okay with certain values of
theta one up to
theta five okay so theta so we we
generate it
and this black curve shows that um the
training data there's not much actually
it's crazy it's these blue dots
so there's just a couple one two three
four five
six seven eight nine ten so we're going
to train
on on those points now let let me make a
couple things pretty clear here
um those blue points um
notice that we don't have any data
suggesting this big dip in the function
not a bit we don't have any data
suggesting
it goes like that um so
i i mean this is pretty crazy uh
to do to to fit this um
okay so what we're gonna do is uh we'll
we'll fit
we'll fit a model using the the uh
train the blue point ten blue points and
we'll evaluate it on the 20 points which
are the red points
okay and the model is going to have
this form it doesn't matter that the
basis functions are sinusoid or
sinusoids it just
it just doesn't that's not relevant okay
so here's what happens and this is
something actually take a
you have to take a good look at it to
kind of figure out make sure what that
works
now when lambda is super small over here
we're basically doing
least squares that's it least scores
data fitting
and it's not bad you know we get you
know um
i don't know what that is like that's
about 0.2 so that's about 0.05 so
basically our um rms error
on the training on the training set is
quite low it's maybe 0.05
on the test set it's 0.2
which is okay that's what it is um but
then you see something interesting
as we increase lambda that's moving
along here
and you can see this is a good example
where i said that we we would vary
lambda over a very wide range on a
logarithmically spaced scale
okay so what happens there is you know
basically as you increase lambda nothing
really happens to the model
until around 10 to the minus one and
what's happening is the coefficients are
now shrinking
and of course the training error gets
worse that's how bi-objective
optimization works right that if you
when you when you crank up lambda the
second objective gets smaller
and the first objective gets bigger and
indeed it goes up and then
roughly speaking for lambda bigger than
100 or so
this is basically the k this is just
basically the constant model
so i would presume that these are
in fact the standard deviations
of the training the test set okay
so that's that but now let's take let's
focus on and see what happens
the training error of course always gets
worse as you increase lambda here's
something amazing
um it's not amazing it kind of makes
sense here you see this dip
very characteristic sometimes it's much
more it's much more pronounced in others
where you really get a much better model
with some regularization
in this case you got a slightly better
somewhat better model actually
with regularization and what this does
is it suggests you should choose
lambda around point one as i said
um sometimes you just take the the one
that gave you the best test error but in
fact usually people kind of
uh skew it to a little bit larger
because you know the more
the less sensitive your model is the
better okay and that's it so we choose
that value
and now what this shows this is called
uh
this is called the regularization path
so
here we think of the coefficients
theta one through theta five um as being
functions of lambda
and then that means that they they trace
out a path
or a curve and so and we'll just plot it
so here's lambda
and here you go you can see oh i should
explain this figure a bit
the these uh dashed lines show
the the value the true
value of the parameters now this is all
completely fake made up data
because you know and so there is such a
thing as the true values of the
parameters they're shown as the dashed
lines
um so if your estimation method did
really well
we would be right on top of those dashed
lines now let me point out the model has
five parameters and we
we fit it on 10 data points so you know
that's we should not expect to do that
well but nevertheless here's what
happens
um up to about lambda equals i don't
know 10 to the minus 3 or 2 or something
like that
it's it's the same something super
interesting happens right in here
right where this is which is where we
what we want to do uh
we think about point one and if we look
at if we go up here and look at point
one
you see something actually kind of
amazing what you see is
right at about where that dip in the
right in in the in the
test error uh dips to its lowest point
right about there actually weirdly our
parameters kind of get
weirdly close to the true parameters so
that's kind of the idea and this is what
regularization does
this is not a very dramatic uh example
sometimes if you have a lot of data you
don't really need regularization
but i don't know the um so i've heard
friends say things like you know friends
don't let friends
fit models without regularization right
because
it's just a good idea to do some regular
and if it turns out they don't need much
regularization that simply means that
you end up
choosing you know a value of lambda
that's
ten to the minus five then that's just
fine uh but in many cases it will
enhance a model
uh the performance of a model very
substantially
right so that's regularized uh data data
fitting
i should say that this is really uh you
know once you know about
least squares data fitting with
regularization you're
you're in you i mean you can be very
effective at building
building models building prediction
models
so i mean this is really that this
this is enough for you to actually go
out and really
do well at this kind of stuff i mean
there's a whole lot more for you to
learn
a lot of this stuff will be interpreted
statistically when you take
you know the course on that and all
sorts of other stuff but
this is kind of the basics